robert spencer
yg hot watch
i started ge hodwatch in 2003 because it
didn't exist and i wanted a site that i
could find all the jihad news
uh every day and so i thought well if
nobody's doing it i'm gonna have to do
it myself and so every day at jihad
watch we post news items that are
generally overlooked about jihad
activity in the united states and around
the world with explanation and
commentary which is of course very
necessary because the establishment
media does its best to whitewash what's
really going on in the great majority of
those stories most people don't realize
how much jihad activity there is still
going on in the united states and
elsewhere and you can find it at
jihadwatch.org